eight seasons in the National Football
League get columnist for SB Nation upon
his retirement in the NFL his brother
again we had on the show back in Kansas
City he's the Chiefs offensive tackle
his brother Mitchell good to see you
Jeff Schwartz how are you brother I'm
good go to be here yeah Jim thank you
for coming here I know we we've been
tweeting this each other now I get to
see each other face to face well we met
another time I told this story we could
we could get into that get into that I
told that to your brother did I tell
this story on the air with his brother
did I tell this story not sure don't
think so um all right as you know doing
NFL gameday mornings long it's a four
hour show and I'm on almost every damn
segment yeah so then I go right into
watching games so it was halftime of the
games and let's just say I I try to have
the same intestinal fortitude as Scott
Hanson does on the set of of red zone I
don't know how he does it
okay basically I mean he's like he's a
camel he holds it only yes so I go
halftime and I run to the bathroom and
the men's room door is locked okay okay
and so I go on to the woman's room
because there was nobody in there and I
did the right thing I I live with a
woman all right now made sure no one was
in their seat up seat back down when I
left okay everything right all right and
I walk out and was staring at me in the
hallway me that's a way to use the
bathroom the right the right bathroom no
no you are not I'd not met you said you
said hi and you know how to go back to
the second half of the games then I saw
you on the air later on again FL
networking I'm like oh my god
yeah I was sitting in that room the
entire time to the very top I got like
snuck in there you guys are all in the
front all the cool kids and you should
be the cool kids I was in the back I'll
tell you what though it's a better spot
I thought that room was gonna be like
fun to watch football and it is but it's
very intense there's a lot going on
those screens well there's people also
working you know I mean like that there
are some people who are like looking at
games to make sure that there
up on everything which that's why I
watch all the early games right I fell
Network cuz you can watch them all at
once that mission control type room yes
but there's some people like taking
notes um yeah people are working I have
three TVs in my house I can watch three
games at once plus the iPad right and
Plus unlike your house and what you do
we're NFL employees we don't have like
some 19 parler working yes just
sometimes sometimes the case yeah just
throwing that out your feed Jeff let's
get into this news of the day how does
Jeff Schwartz here on the Richard show
how does the Julio Jones exception that
was clearly made on his behalf and how
rare is that that we just saw it's very
rare I can remember a couple instances
where guys got deals basically before
that kind of two year left on contract
window where teams are more willing to
do deals it's kind of not even a deal
though it's just a little little piece
of what he was gonna get next year when
they were gonna renegotiate that anyways
and they just flipped it to him this
year to keep him happy if that's what he
if he goes you know what that would make
me happy what's the problem
it sets precedent teams don't like to do
that we saw at the Steelers they don't
want to pay levy on bail like a hybrid
player they don't want to set that
precedent of having to do that teams
very rarely do this but Julio was that
great of a player that they need him in
camp they need him to be part of the
team they want him to be happy so
they're just really at no expense to
them for the Kapiti thing is through him
some money I think it's fabulous I wish
more team to do this but guys don't have
the leverage that Julio has so the
question is how does it play in a locker
room when they when they well knowing
that that that exception will not be
made I am pretty much I think you pretty
much know where your place in the locker
you know if you're at the higher the
pecking order the lower there are not
many guys who probably feel comfortable
even asking for more money you have to
have a certain level of clout we know
that I think gals will be happy he got
paid there'll be a couple guys prying
that locker and we say hey why did the
Falcons hook me up I know Ron the NFL my
brother for example needs to make more
money
playing simple he's 1 or 2 right tackle
he's been second team All Pro last two
years he does not make enough money for
his position so you look at a guy like
that and he can maybe say hey Chiefs
look what the Falcons did to Julio
while he hooked me up he's got vom
Miller twice a year
not twice a year Joey Bosa twice a year
hooked me up with some of this money so
I think maybe guys around the NFL now
will point to the phallus of Falcon
example and say look if Atlas did this
why don't you hook up your players who
are underpaid well I mean and then
obviously there are some and I was
talking about this with Adam Schefter
yesterday on the show Jeff Schwartz
eight-year NFL veteran here today that
part of the fact that there's more
holdouts is that they players are seeing
how much money's going down in the NBA
being given it yes the contracts that in
the same day that Todd Gurley had an
unprecedented deal handed to him with
Rams for running back for years 60 it
was four years how much for for Kevin
Love and torn Rahman it was 121 so right
and so so that that's guaranteed money
yes what about the that fact of the hour
NFL players and and Kirk Cousins right
playing on a rare guaranteed all
guaranteed deal coming up this year so
what about that oh yeah I like the
players can joke about it but if you get
serious with it I don't understand that
you have to understand I'm very Pro
player you got to understand the
politics and also how many players we
have versus how many players NBA has how
much leverage you know the NBA is a
player's league players will get more
money there's also less players right so
you get more money cap NFL is obviously
not so much a player's league I love the
idea of guaranteed contracts but I think
it's unrealistic for NFL players to
expect to negotiate that into our next
CBA you can't guarantee 53 guys what's
gonna happen if that happens salaries
will lower themselves big time for teams
what do you mean
so I signed a four-year deal with the
Giants for 16 million right and I had
about the first two years guaranteed and
the Giants probably would not offer me
that same deal if it was full guarantee
they'd offer me less years and less
money maybe around the same average per
year but players on these long-term
deals for couple reasons one because
they think they're gonna play out they
think they're gonna play the five-year
deal and get all the money not worry
about the guarantee to the team's want
to spread the signing bonus over the
five-year five or six year so I think
it's unrealistic to assume we're all
gonna get guaranteed contracts I mean
what cousins did is fabulous it makes a
lot of business sense get the money for
three years can go get another
three-year deal I think we should fight
for couple things in the CBA but one of
them is a
LT for cutting a guy early if I got cut
after two years hey the Giants owe me 25
percent of my deal whatever it is that's
more realistic in my opinion because I
don't know what we'd give up to get
guaranteed contracts for everyone so
your idea would be you've got a four
year deal yeah if you are cut before the
end of your four years yes even if the
back two years were not guaranteed
dollars some thanks percent of it
yes percentage of it that seems to make
more sense than just saying I get a four
year guaranteed contract because that's
not realistic for all 53 guys in the
rough too many injuries too much money
spread around I just don't think the
contract values would be the same if
they were all guaranteed quarterbacks
different you got to take them out
you're gonna pay your quarterback
guaranteed money but you're gonna pay
thee and I was another thoughtful
offensive lineman I mean you gonna pay
me a guaranteed contract for a guy who
might not play all year might get cut
might go to practice squad doesn't seem
to make sense to fight for that to give
up whatever we give up in the
negotiation it's interesting you say the
NFL is not a player's league I think
fantasy football's changing that because
yes the number of Millennials that come
up to me that I have conversations with
based on you know whether I'm seeing him
at a bar mitzva seeing a mountain about
they they don't come up to me and say
how's Team X gonna do this year right
off steam wha gonna do this year how's
my team gonna do this year they say Who
am I drafted in fantasy and that way if
I see him in October or November they're
they're talking about their fantasy I
mean they're not talking to me about
their favorite team in the NFC West that
they grew up with I'm serious I'm
talking about more at the top like the
structure of the NBA is more of a
player's kind of run things and NFL the
players think they might run hey they
don't and that's some talk about fantasy
football it's been great for our sport
it's grown the sport I agree with you
the fan base thinks it's a player's
league coming from the very top
the NFL is not a player's leave I hope I
hope it becomes that way I think we're
moving in that direction to allow
players more freedom socially and just
allowing players to have more thoughts
outside of football all right take a
60-second break come back and I want to
ask you
the number one trend you think is going
to be offensively in the NFL this year
and then just to open it wide up to your
career and a little bit more about you
sir good to see you Jeff Schwartz Jeff
Schwartz is here on the rich Eisen shore
back in 60 seconds Anthony Davis of the
New Orleans pelicans still to come
all right welcome back to the Rick
Johnson show Jeff Schwartz former
Panther Viking chief Giants and then a
little bit of cup of coffee with the
Lions where you you wrap things up in
your NFL career so the Eagles RPO seems
to me could be the copy yeah moment
anybody wins the Super Bowl right like
the Seahawks won the Super Bowl but he
wanted to get long corners yes just as
it for instance now we're seeing an RPO
team winning the Super Bowl with a
backup quarterback reviewing and he
wasn't even a threat to do the are yeah
the question so do you think we're gonna
see more of that this year probably but
I will caution you
New England stop the RPO in the Super
Bowl the Eagles broke down the first
half really when the Eagles tried to do
it they legals running ran 36 players
around 6 rpoS
and the Patriots just dropped the guy
back and eagles couldn't throw the ball
well the Eagles did though is they can
run the football they have a great
offensive line so if you try to RPO and
someone takes away the pass you have to
still run the ball
so yeah off its last to be good your
running backs have to be good yeah it's
a good situation teams will try it but
unless you have an offensive minded head
coach someone who really knows and has
studied how RPO is work and that's why
teams went down to Oklahoma to visit
Lincoln Riley to visit some of these
colleges it's not gonna be successful
for everyone who tries to run it hmm so
there's a couple things if Nick Foles
you'll have a really good running back
behind a good offensive line in front of
him and run a play where there's a
running back next to him and you don't
know if the run and that's taking it or
not and it's just like a fake and all
four he's giving it all the team's can't
do that I mean with a with a quarterback
who is as good as Nick Foles and but
everybody's got good running backs and
obviously offensive line play shouldn't
be taken for granted but the reason why
I don't think everyone can do it is is
you know there were times where the
Eagles would read like the linebacker
right and a linebacker has to stay put
with a linebacker you like the will
linebacker let's say okay they just get
the Chargers a bunch of week for there
to read the will or the will has to kind
of stay put because if they do hand the
ball
off he's got to tackle the guys he knows
they can run the football right um if
you're not worried about that you'll
just drop back into coverage and so
everything has to everything has to play
a role I think we're gonna see teams do
is do kind of what the Rams have done
which is romp 2 line of scrimmage get
everyone set and then Shaun McVeigh uses
the the the quarterback system and it
calls another play which doesn't happen
very often most times you call a play
and you let the quarterback decide what
to do next
he gives golf to play yes I think we're
gonna see that tempo more often than
we're gonna see the rpoS Tom Brady's not
running an RPO like I think you have to
have a very specific sure offensive
coordinator who knows what he's doing
and also have the players to execute
that so when you say that the Patriots
stopped the SunPass option this off the
pass option about well that they
couldn't stop the pass period what all
came down to it where do you stand on
the subject of the day that came out of
the Q&A with Belichick in an hour third
our guest yesterday Dan Shaughnessy do
you think Malcolm Butler playing in that
game would have been a difference
between winning and losing a Super Bowl
do you think other would've been the
difference between winning or losing
super would have helped obviously I mean
if the right guard blocks Brandon grand
the Patriots plug go down and score the
last drive and win the game anyways
there's many little instances where the
Patriots could have won the game it
would help tell me how he just signed a
massive deal obviously someone thought
he was good enough to sign this a big
deal so of course it would've helped if
he played are you sitting in a Patriots
locker room I'm wondering about that yes
to this day yes I mean I think there
will be a especially guys that have not
won many Super Bowls there they will
always think about that so the Malcolm
Butler interception that proved to
linger in the Seahawks locker yes this
Malcolm Butler
I guess benching has the possibility in
your mind to play that role in New
England I'm not sure it's that intense
because it did physically at one point
it lose them the game that's one of my
favorite topics by the way so and I want
to get us that I made the right call
passing the football okay finish your
thought and then once yes I don't think
it will linger like that because the
pitchers have also won a lawsuit will
sit there done a lot of women they could
go back this year and win and everyone
forgets that that happened but I think
there will always be a question also
because we've never really heard why it
happened Malcolm Butler doesn't know I
think Bilbao sucks only one
and he's not gonna show the information
so now you think the Patriots that the
yes that that the the Seahawks made the
right call to throw on the goal on
instead of handing it off to yes I wrote
about this I know you did if you if you
look at the box so what what happened is
the Patriots used a personnel group on
defense they haven't used very well they
don't use very often they had a goal
line front yeah I said six defensive
linemen and they put in three corners so
I took out a linebacker they normally
have a goal line package and put an
extra corner in the game which teams
don't typically do so if you're Seattle
you're an 11 personnel one tight end and
one running back there are serious you
come to a line of scrimmage there are
too many guys to block it's not gonna
work in the leverage was terrible he
Vince Wilfork was way on the Y in the
guard he would have shoved everything
back to the unblocked guy it was not
gonna work not gonna work the pass was
the right call you can argue whether the
actual concept was right but in 2013 the
pick play was huge that's what a lot of
teams ran give credit to the Patriots
they knew was coming and they made the
right play it was not the wrong call to
past you can argue if the past was the
actual concept was the right decision
which now obviously it looks bad but the
action of passing was the right call how
how did the Patriots do it cuz it we
were talking about earlier and I'd like
to for you to get into it when you
played the Patriots oh yeah they they
were unique how so what the Patriots to
better than anyone NFL I can't believe
people don't are not more that is not
the copycat or the copy they just can
turn their team into whatever they need
week to week so we sit off that's all
the time you know one week Brady throws
55 times and they run seven well next
week they run for 40 times in Brady
throws for 25 Jonas gray goes into B Pro
Football Hall of Fame based on one night
we don't even does it now defensively I
remember 2015 we played them is really
the first time I think I'd played them
where I was starting we played him in
Carolina so I don't remember quite that
but we came out we didn't know what
defense they were gonna run there were
three options that could road they have
a three man in front of five man front
or like a fourth Thibault fourth and
this is what you talked about all
weekend you're meeting but we're like
have to know how to block all these
fronts because we don't know what
they're gonna come out and basin and
it's the only team that doesn't have to
prepare like that yes
now most teams you know their base you
know their sub fronts now they might
have some walk-around stuff and some
weird stuff week to week but we did
legit do not know which base defense
that we're gonna be and they were in the
third of the three options on Sunday the
one that you expected the least they're
in yeah it's crazy
and that's why they just have a lot of
interchangeable parts on defense they
have guys that can rush the passer drop
into coverage they have guys that can
rush the passer and also you know wolf
or could rush the passer at this size I
mean he was he could do multiple things
that's why they had these
interchangeable parts on defense and
that's why they draft the way that they
dress I guess and then they turn your
third stringer into their Pro Bowler
yeah never done is recently but that I
give you I submit to you the name of Rex
Burkhead sir it's not like he was a Pro
Bowler but I mean in that all in that
and they can just rotate it like one
week and that's why it's so hard
we'll see what does he let's put it this
way we'll see what Dion Lewis looks like
down in Tennessee much better offensive
line there though I mean it'd be
interesting to see what new what new OC
will suit that you want let me ask you
this question how will the Nate's older
loss affect the Patriots this year do
you think they drafted Isaiah win and I
was a 24th pick from Georgia to play
left tackle he's a monster he's really
good they made the right pick here I
think they'll put him in left tackle
they won't miss him very much
I think I looked at this last year Tom
Brady has primarily played with two left
tackles in his entire career like 95% of
the games like insult older flying
soldier it's crazy and the best
offensive line on the league is in
Philly I was thought you see Kansas City
oh yes the Chiefs the right tackle but
you did not starter when you just spat
out Billy it was good oh boy
yeah they're good do they gonna repeat
this here anything I like the Falcons in
the NFC I think we see Falcons Patriots
again you'd you'd you'd you'd take that
one when you Chris you take that one
yeah as long as the Pats figure out how
to cover the running back out of the
backfield but you know what so you say
the Falcons are gonna play for it all an
error in their own building yeah you
make sense son let's have a Superboy
- so no that's why you're saying that
that plant how's your brother gonna feel
that you chose the Eagles over his
offensive line
you think campus practice this morning I
think he'll survive I don't know we'll
let him know maybe stone streets out
watching testing your brother right now
about brisket and that too last one very
important this is very important this
question is for me Chris okay okay these
questions for me how many Jews are there
in the National definitely more Jewish
owners I had I had a a trainer of mine
who would say almost every day you
should be only the team not playing for
it okay but was a Lamar Pett was on the
Bucs
yeah my brother obviously I guess - its
- Adam busines Wadi he was on the Giants
I think they released him so that's
obviously three yes there's not know
there's many there's there's it depends
also what are we are we clarifying that
it's the mother is Jewish like there's a
lot of tradition yeah yeah yeah yeah I
mean I'll take anything anymore
there's not many we used to have backup
quarterbacks and kickers I think those
are kind of gone it's Edelman yes Jewish
yes I don't know always says he's Jew
ish I think Edelman actually qualifies
yes I think he does yeah so that's four
okay so we're halfway to being able to
hold a Sabbath
we're actually intended to be ten that's
a minute you still almost make a million
when I was in the league with like eight
this Taylor maze was playing so I was
obviously in Saint Joseph it was still
playing well one of one of the items
that we have here on our set that's
never shown on television walk over
there great Jews in sports would you
autograph that yeah it's not a pamphlet
it is a thick ass book okay it is
significant because it's about the
history of the entirety of sports in
America okay so we go back yeah it's
it's it's it's we buried it why do we
have the great Jews and sports book
completely buried on the on our set I
mean it's got its own spot everything
here has its place there it is coach
sallet looks like it's on the front
cover I'm and I'm an inductee in the
Southern California Jewish Sports Hall
of Fame
hey yeah who else is in there call
facts right a lots of people are I mean
coach there's also media members are in
there okay I was casta wide I wouldn't
like the yard when it was me my brother
Ramona Shelburne Mark Steyn hey a couple
like college softball player hockey
player all right someone played for the
Israeli World Baseball Classic team my
favorite moment of my interview with
your brother right the best part about
this is it's revised and updated with an
introduction by Red Auerbach cannot be
the stick is real man
max Freeman pioneer basketball turn it
all the way to the back well how many
pages is there what the book ends on
what page the Maccabi Games are back
here yeah yeah the book ends what's the
last number 31 331 pages there's no line
wow this is this is actually like my
favorite el David part of the interview
with your brother and Stonestreet is I
said to him you know great to have a
member of his tribe on the show and
stone tree goes gee I saw that hey it's
good to see you Jeff Schwartz lied to me
here coming on the show and you're
welcome here any time I'll get you on
the phone whenever test in Los Angeles
Jeff Schwartz follow him on Twitter it's
GE o FF Schwartz the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience